but tonight uh encourage people to keep
coming later and later
uh we have two talks this morning it's a
pleasure to introduce adnan
darwish who's our first speaker uh he's
a
vladimir is well known to the sac
community for having worked on showing
that cdcl
can simulate resolution but he's uh
also worked extensively in uh in ai
topics included
including including machine learning and
bayesian networks among other things
and he's speaking today on branching
on formulas a perspective from knowledge
compilation
thank you all right thank you sam so all
right so
yes branching on formulas as opposed to
branching on variables i think this is a
very interesting
distinction that comes up quite
practically as you will see but it's a
subject that i don't think has
received perhaps a systematic treatment
as
much as it should be it's one thing that
i
mentioned in my class graduate class on
the subject quite a bit as something
where
more work needs to be done so let's see
what's going on here so
branching on variables uh or branching
here i mean case analysis
uh this is a profound entrenched
technique in
uh automated reasoning right so we try
to solve a problem
and we try to solve
uh simpler problems in order to solve
the original
more complex problem and we do this by
uh looking at cases so
uh with branching on variables i
basically say try x is true try x is
false
and uh you can see this is like a basis
for
set solvers in resolution uh if x is
false then alpha if x is true then beta
and therefore i conclude alpha or beta
i'm doing case analysis on variables the
influential bull shannon expansion is
based on this notion as well
i can rewrite the formula by
conditioning it
on x being true x being false i can join
this with a positive literal x with a
negative literal and then i can rewrite
it like this and there's so many
applications of course this is the basis
of dpl
but has even more direct and powerful
uses
as we will see later
now the point is uh
there is a more general of branching or
case analysis and that is
a case analysis on formulas and what
does that mean
so in the simplest form i'm gonna go and
and solve my problem by saying assume
alpha then assume that alpha or alpha is
an arbitrary sentence
and um you can even do this more
generally
by uh branching on a set of sentences so
in this case i have a set of senses
alpha one through alpha n and i'm gonna
say assume alpha one
and then assume alpha two dot uh where
these alphas are exhaustive so
i'm covering the cases but not simply by
looking at a
literal lens negation now this
generalizes this not just in the sense
of having
uh multiple formulas instead of two
uh there's something very important here
this uh these two cases are mutually
exclusive
uh here this does not require that so
the cases that i'm looking
at may overlap and uh they could be
mutually exclusive but they don't have
to be and that's actually
subtle but important distinction so they
could or could not be mutually exclusive
this is more general and actually
these do not have to be exhaustive uh
they just have to cover the cases that
you know are possible so instead of just
requiring okay this is instead of this
implying equal to true and there's a
typo
or whether they're just implied by my
input formula so
other distinctions when you go and do a
branching on formula so the bottom line
is this bottom line is
if you're branching on variables bottom
line is you may be doing
exponentially more work than necessary
and
the way we're going to approach this uh
is from the viewpoint of knowledge
compilation we'll see what that is later
and and the bottom line ends up being a
little bit sharper
in the sense that not only
are you doing exponentially more work
but we can tell you
more specifically you are actually
solving a harder problem than you really
need to
than the problem you're really trying to
to solve if you branch on variables and
why is what's the interaction with
knowledge compilation and why we're
bringing this into
this distinction and the subject for two
reasons one of them is in knowledge
compilation we have to build knowledge
compilers
uh a little bit more powerful things
than set solvers
they target problems beyond np
and this notion comes up a lot and this
is how i got into this because
and you'll see this practically later
you will need to think about this and
you realize that you're limited if you
branch on variables now the other
interesting thing is
what you'll see is the knowledge
compilation provides
very interesting and short theoretical
tools to talk about this distinction
and the implications so it's there's a
practical interest in addressing this
problem or studying it
but it also happens that the problem
that needs it has the tools to talk
about it and that's what we're gonna see
today so
before i move on let me just say one
thing
so we know this in a sense from a long
time ago
that branching on formulas versus
variables is
powerful and the story comes from
extended resolution
we know that we have some problems
that have exponential the size
resolution proofs but
publicized extended resolution proofs
and
if you see what happens in extended
resolution
we add these rules we introduce these
auxiliary variables
that we equate to in this case simple
type of formula
and this can be thought of as these
clauses but really what's going on here
is
if i go and say assume x then i'm
effectively
assuming this formula and assume not x
i'm actually looking at its negation so
what's happening is something very
interesting which is
i'm using uh branching on variables to
emulate
the branching or formulas now i'm going
to be telling you
two concrete stories about branching on
formulas and the rest of the talk
and the second one will actually allude
to this
technique there is a lot more that can
be said
about it because this is a little bit
too specific here but
just to point this out so this this
notion of auxiliary variables and using
them to emulate
branching or formulas has been
established for a while and it's pretty
important we're gonna get to it so
i said i'm gonna tell you two stories
about branching on formulas
and i just need a little bit of
background or knowledge compilation
before we
uh move on so let me go ahead and do
that
now and and invoke a couple of tools
that we need for this purpose
what is known as compilation now the
classical definition
is it's some kind of processing
technique you give me an input formula i
want to do something i go and compile it
into something else and i facilitate
what i want to do later by amortizing my
efforts that i did in the offline
compilation phase during the online
phase okay
this is outdated in a sense
knowledge competition has been around
for about 40 years perhaps in ai
and the last 20 years looked very
different from the ones before
and as you see what happened with
knowledge comparison it
it's not an a it is it in a sense it's
it's it ended up being a methodology for
computation what do i mean by that
we take an input formula and compile it
into something and we insist that that
something is tractable
for the task that we want which means
the time you finish compilation you're
done there's no more
anything to be aided afterwards it's the
end story
if i succeed in compiling and what
happened
over the last years is an explosion of
study of what i combined into
which tend to be circuits and tractable
circuits in particular
and negative normal form circuits even
more specifically there's a whole family
of these circuit types
that we try to combine into and we have
a wealth of knowledge that has been
built by the community
about these circuit types their powers
their relative success and so on and
we're going to invoke these tools
next so uh
negation normal form circuits which is
the subject of
what most of what's been happening in
the last three years is pretty simple
uh these are circuits with three types
of gates
inverters ands and ores you have one
restriction
the inverters can only appear next to
inputs so what i have is a circuit where
either
the inputs are either variables or
they're negations and then i have layers
of hands and ores no restrictions on
ants and ores fannings fanouts and so on
okay this is by itself is not very
interesting
in fact and it's also not restricted so
if your ores are not
at the input you can always push them to
the input while at most doubling the
size of the circuit okay
things get interesting when you start
adding properties to these circuits and
then they become
tractable that is they start doing
things that are hard in general so
there's so many of these and so many
properties and therefore circuit types
i'm not going to talk about this i
talked
two hours about this a month ago at
the beyond set workshop here i'm going
to just mention two properties it's
going to be
decomposability which is the property
you impose and you get a type of
circuits called dnr circuits
gives you sad so satisfiability becomes
easy
and another property called determinism
if you add on top of the composability
you get a new circuit types called
ddnf and then sharp set becomes easier
you can do some set easy with that so
that circuit type has been very
important in modern counting problems
and so on so we're going to talk about
these next
and some separation results that will be
the basis
of further talking about
branching on formulas versus variables
the composite is very simple
it applies to and gates it's a property
about end gates it says if you have
an and gate and you look at the
sub-circuits that feed into it they
those circuits cannot sub-circuits
cannot share variables uh so in this
case i'm highlighting two sub-circuits
and one of them mentions the variable lk
the other is pa they do not overlap and
by the way this
looks like a tree uh but it's actually
the circuit like you have
l here and l there but we're just laying
it out this way for visual convenience
you want every and gate to such files
property any subsequence feeding a dude
cannot
share the variables and then it's called
the composable dnf and
status easy on the sky believe it or not
linear time
in fact you can do something else in
linear time which subsumes that and i'm
going to mention it on the next slide
because we're going to need it later so
existential quantification so you can
existentially quantify
any number of variables in linear time
from these circuits
while maintaining the composability so
the input is a dna of the output is a b
and
f and the process is super simple here's
at a dnf i want to existentially
quantify the variables x and z
and the process simply says look for
every occurrence of these variables
whether negative or positive and replace
it by true
and that's it the result is a tractable
circuit in dnn4
and it is uh
basically you can see how this allows
you to do that because you can exist to
multiply every variable and easily test
whether the
resulting circuit is constant true or
false
uh what uh a couple of weeks ago so
pratik talked about
uh the importance of extensive
quantification in functional synthesis
uh his group is actually and colleagues
is even introducing new circuit types
that
they particularly target essential
quantitation okay let's talk about the
second property
to finish this uh part on background
determinism determinism is another
influential property
and it's a property of or gates
or gates and if i put this property on
top of the composability then i can do
sharp set i can count
models satisfying assignments easily and
the property is pretty simple
if you look at the inputs of any or gate
in your circuit let's look at the top
one
and call the inputs alpha one alpha two
alpha three i just want this to be
mutually exclusive
all right that's it and i want this for
every or game
so if i have this with the composability
you can do counting and poly time if you
have another property called smoothness
which i'm gonna skip
it's easy to enforce it's a convenience
property you can actually do it in
linear time and and
let me show it's super simple i wanna
count the models of this guy this is
both decomposable and deterministic
uh you basically feed ones and zeros in
the input
every literal lens negation get one
constants get one or zero
and you just add that or gates multiply
and and gates and da da da
and that tells you already this circuit
has nine satisfying assignments out of
16 it has actually four variables
this has been pretty influential circuit
type because you can do it
modicum can do weighted model counting
you pass weights instead of numbers
and reductions for probabilistic reason
to bullying formulas then to this
commonplace uh today based on that
okay now i cheated i told you i'm gonna
only do two circuit
types uh i'm gonna do one more
and we finish this background but let me
just say a word which is also going to
be significant in the second story
about existential quantification while
existentially quantifying variables from
dnf is easy it is not on deterministic
simply because there's no polynomial
algorithm for this
because a formula may have a compact
deterministic decomposable
representation but if you essentially
quantify variables from it the result
may explode
now this formula that i showed you
before and i told you was dnf
and i existentially quantified it
actually also it happens to be
deterministic so this is actually a
deterministic dnf
so what happens if i apply the procedure
that i told you about
well since this is a dnnf the procedure
works
so this is indeed the existential
quantification of that but
the the the difference is while this is
both deterministic and decomposable i
cannot guarantee you that the output is
deterministic can be composable i can
only guarantee you that it's
decomposable
and this is going to be essential in one
of the
main insights later about branching on
variables versus
branching on variables we're going to
invoke
this notion that i can easily
quantify existentially quantify on dnf
but if i
quantify a deterministic circuits i'm
only guaranteed to get decomposable but
i i would
lose determinism in general okay so in
this case
this was deterministic the top or node
but it's no longer deterministic and the
result okay guys as i said i cheated i i
needed one more circuit type
which is very significant from a
practical point of view this is a subset
of the last circuit type
which is deterministic dnf it's called
decision dnf and the idea here i want
determinism but in a very specific way i
want every or gate to look like this
two inputs only one input is an end gate
the other is an
end gate and here you have a variable
alpha not very good alpha so this guy
represents
this formula you can see it's
deterministic it's mutually exclusive
but the conflict is very specific it's a
conflict on a specific
variable and this ends up being a subset
of the previous guy
you see why this is significant in
practice
and it's tied to this notion of
splitting on variables versus splitting
on formulas
is in fact one of the implications of
splitting on variables which is so
commonplace and that is actually pinning
us
in a hole in a sense as you will see
later okay quickly here
to wrap up this part these three circuit
types are exponentially separated
so if you go from the composable
uh negational form you add determinants
we get an exponential separation
this was shown unconditionally recently
there was a conditional
result from a while back if you have not
determinism but decision determinism
instead of the general
type of determinism you also get an
exponential separation
uh this was actually shown a few years
back in conference papers
by we be men as folks but this is the
more general
version and these separations are going
to be critical for what we're going to
see
later but the basic story is if you
try to use branch
on variables in a very broad context you
are committing yourself to these guys
and you are really missing out big time
and if you want to go
up the hierarchy of these things you
have to branch on formulas that's the
gist of the
story and i'll show you how later and
the interesting thing that's going to
come up from this story
is i can characterize what you're doing
in terms of
what you committed yourself to and what
kind of problems you're really solving
not the one you think you are solving
but the one you
are indeed solving if you branch on
variables we can characterize
that by talking about which circuit
types are you actually compiling we're
going to make this very sharp as you
will see
two other circuit types so so they're
going to be two stories next
uh the second story would refer to these
and their separations and the
existential quantifications that i've
mentioned the first story
we refer to two other circuit types
which will come up on the way as we go
on
ovds i guess a lot of people know that
there is a generalization called sdds
they're also exponentially separated
and these two guys are not comparable so
there are functions that can be easily
represented by this will blow up by that
and the other way around
and these two papers show beam and you
showed that
this can blow up while this can be
compact this more recent results show
the other way
around and i wish to thank pierre
marquis and alexis the corner for
helping out with
uh figuring out all of the details of
these separation results okay
folks let's go to the first story but if
you want to hear more about knowledge
compilation
and this you know very rich picture
this is the original paper that laid out
this
picture that i'm mentioning here there's
a more recent tutorial
uh five year actually there was a five
week five day workshop in france and
there was a tutorial on knowledge
compilations available online
you can see my two hour that i gave a
month ago
but let's go over the first story on
branching on formulas all right so
uh in this story the bottom line is
we're going to generalize
branching on variables to formulas in
specifically and we're going to get a
very concrete exponential
separation practically uh that's
basically what's going to happen here
and
what we're going to do is we're going to
generalize the shuttle expansion so the
general expansion
is is the case analysis of variables and
i want to go into something like this
uh instead of saying x or not x i'm
gonna go and
do case analysis on formulas
and you're gonna see the the
implications of this
and um now we're gonna say wait a minute
what does this mean
what are these alphas where do i get
them from what does it even mean to
condition a form
a function a boolean function on a
formula you know how to condition it on
a variable setting
we're going to see this the the crux of
what i'm going to tell you is the
following
this expansion is unique once you give
me the variable so if you come until the
x expand on x here it is no choices
this that i'm going to show you next is
also unique but
instead of a variable i want a set of
variables from and once you give me a
set of variables i'm going to show you
how to do it this way
where these formulas are going to be
over those variables so i'm going to be
branching on formulas that
refer to some variables and you give me
those variables
here's how it works here's the formula i
want to expand it as i just mentioned so
as i said i need variables from you
to do these alphas on and you go and
choose a
and b what i'm going to show you now is
not how it works in practice because
this is not practical but this is to
conceptually explain how we're going to
branch on formulas
you give me your variables and here's
what i'm going to do i'm going to look
at every instantiation of these
variables and there's four of them
and i'm going to condition the the the
function or the boolean formula on these
guys
that's well defined these are variable
instantiations i'm gonna get this
and then i'm gonna do one more thing
anytime these conditionings
match i'm gonna combine them so this
case and that case get combined how by
disjoining these two guys so i'm gonna
get this now
now i'm going to keep repeating this
until there is no more
joining or collapsing of cases that can
happen
and then i'm done and there's only one
way of doing this this process
this guy is unique once you tell me what
are the variables that you want to do
case analysis on
and so what i did in this case once you
told me what a and b
is uh these are the two cases that i
combined here
uh i rewrote my function like this and
using our notation that's what i did so
these are my cases alpha 1 alpha 2 alpha
3 they're
mutually exclusive and exhaustive and we
call these primes
we call these guys sums so i have prime
multiplied by sum
and this is something that i call the
compressed x y partition about a decade
ago when i introduced it now
what is y y is every other variable so
you fix
x and this is a b y here would be c
d and one thing you have to observe is
while the alphas
are by construction are over x the
these are the primes the sums are over
the y variables
so x y x y and the order matters here
if you flip that it's a different story
you get a different
expansion now i'm going to tell you the
implications of this
and how big of a deal this turned out to
be
branching on formulas but let me just
mention one more thing i talked about
this briefly a month ago at the beyond
set workshop and kerbs
brought up orthonormal expansions
frankly i just thought they might
remember we had this discussion
you can remember what they were and
later he was kind enough to
send me a screenshot from a book
uh for old book in which
uh this is defined also normal
expansions you have a function
uh you rewrite it like this and these
guys are mutually exclusive and
exhaustive
all right so what's the relation to what
i just showed what i just showed is a
very specific instance of this this puts
no conditions on these guys
remember what we have if you want to
call these primes and these subs
i require these to be over a set of
variables x and these to be over a
disjoint set of variables y
i require these guys to be distinct so
yes it is the complex xy partition is an
instance of an orthonormal expansion and
so is the [ __ ] on expansion
is an instance of compressed xy
partition and therefore
an instance of orthonormal expansions
but both of these guys get their
properties because of the additional
properties they impose and i don't know
if you've noticed but
if you choose your x to be a single
variable then this
reduces to the channel pool expansion
okay now we get to the punch
line and move to the next story uh
what's the punch line what do i do with
this how does this help me what
what is the exponential separation how
do i use it for well
what do we use the shannon bull
expansion for one of the major uses in
the construction
of obts you know about obdd's some
people tell you this is perhaps
the most studied attractive
representation of green circus they're
decision graphs
like this that represent the boolean
formulas
and they have an ordering of the
variables so the variables x y
z uh okay that's the classical
definition but they're just circuits
they're negation normal form circuits if
you expand
this decision node notation
x go this way x not x go that way you
rewrite it like
x and da not x and y if you want to see
our circuit notation that's what's going
on
all of these three different notations
are the same thing so these are
negation normal form circuits and how do
i obtain them for a boolean formula i
obtained them by a repeated application
of the would sharon expansion how
remember first i need a variable
ordering because to apply that expansion
i need to know what variables to apply
so in this case the the order is x y z
so what do i do you give me
the boolean function f and you said x y
z
okay let's expand on x okay i got my
first portion of the obd
uh x and this or not x
and that and then what do i do i take
each one of these guys and again
expand it using the bool channel
expansion and i need a variable
you gave me an ordering so it's going to
be y i take this guy expand on y
and then now i got my second part here
so i'm conditioning this on not
y and y you repeat this
pretty simple canonical
one of the biggest thing about odds is
it's unique
if you give me the variable order there
is no other way of doing this there's
only one way of doing this
so i get you a canonical representation
so
now that we can branch on formulas using
also economical expansion the question
is what happens if i
don't do this but i use the xy partition
to compress xy partition what happens
well you get another type of circuits
and and but you're gonna send me but
wait a minute two millimeters a second
here i know how to apply it because i i
need a variable order and that tells me
exactly what to do at every step
of the recursive decomposition what are
you going to do for the other guy
every time you need a set of variables
how are you going to specify that so
that you can guide me into applying this
uniquely
right uh here's the function if you
choose your x and therefore y is
determined
you expand it like this into primes and
subs now i'm gonna have to expand each
one of these guys are gonna tell me the
choices of these guys
there is a simple notion called ev3 very
variable tree full binary tree where the
leaves are
my variables and this fully specifies
what you need to do case analysis on
every step of the recursion
so the root node tells you what to do
for the very first function it's telling
you the left variables
are x the right variables are y okay so
you know what to do first step
here now if you're going to go expand
these this tells you let's pick the
primes
then you go to this node and this v3
tells you how to do it so now
this is x and this is y so this v3 tells
you at
every step what variables to
do case analysis on and therefore branch
own sentence is on
and that uniquely determines the output
and the output is known as an std
sentential decision diagram i introduced
this
bar a decade ago there's strict
generalization of obdds and they are
exponentially separated as shown by over
a few years
back so this is one story about
branching on sentences as opposed to
variables and the exponential impact
that it has
there is an open source sdd package if
you want to see a picture of an sdd what
we've been looking at is an sdp
actually uh this is uh the first
expansion here
the first xy decomposition prime subs
pretty powerful circuit types if you
have a formula and you compile it into
one of these guys with an appropriate v3
you can do mesh mesh set
pp to the pp complete and linear time of
these guys
all right uh i have an online course
which has a couple of hours or three
hours on these circuits if you need
to know more about them you can find
this from my
youtube channel just type you say layout
medium group you will find that and let
me see how much time
uh so i have about 10 10 15 more minutes
sam
for the second story excellent that's
okay okay
very good so now i'm telling the second
story the second story is more
intriguing
because more open-ended so the first one
looks like seven yes it is a
success story nice closed in a sense
and this one is a little bit more
intricate
because it's kind of open-ended and gets
more to the mainstream way of doing
things today
and the short story is i'll tell you i'm
going to invoke another tool
from knowledge compilation or another
major development so let me just briefly
tell you what it is
the short story is this algorithms
that do search based on
variable splitting and variable
branching
you can talk about these algorithms
uh as as living traces you can sit and
watch them do the work
and as they go to different places you
mark things on the side
and you can show that they are actually
writing out circuits
their traces are circuit types as in
i showed you uh earlier so
they are implicit knowledge compilers
they're doing enough work to compile
their input formula
and we're going to formalize this and
it's very easy to formalize
and the idea is once i establish the
trace of your algorithm
i can tell you about it i can tell you
where it will fail
because i know that for
those input formulas if you're in trace
x i know that it cannot represent things
using x compactly and i tell you where
you will succeed so
we will use this tool we will establish
this notion of a phrase and then use it
to tell you about
how severe is this notion of branching
on variables and current context
is and what it takes to do to break away
from this and
and really do things way more
efficiently the notion of a trace is
pretty simple
you look at something like exam and we
do this with uh
jumbo wang you look at the formula like
this and if you run exhaustive dpl on it
we know what that is right you're
searching in a tree by fixing the values
of variables
if you are doing sad then you're done in
this case
dbll keeps going and initially people
propose this to count models right so
you keep going and you try the other
branch of
x and da da da and then now you
terminate so you basically
exhausted dpl or exhaustively now
i'll show you how this is a rewrite of
your input formula as
a circuit compilation and we know this
by now how to translate something like
this into
something like that this decision node x
force go this way x to go that way
that's this fragment here right so this
simple
uh rewrite or trace is this now this is
not interesting because this is a tree
but actually this is it
equivalent to your input formula so it
is error right
now what happened is people over the
years
did a whole bunch of advances to these
search algorithms uh
and i'm gonna show you three of them
quickly and
you'll see that each advance leads to a
new circuit type
if you keep it race like i showed you
you get a different circuit type so you
could
you get to see the power of these
techniques
by looking at what they did to the
traces
you add one technique you get a new type
of traces
and i know that they're exponentially
separated from the previous ones
i can analyze what you did
algorithmically using tools from
knowledge compilation and what i know
about success of these things
i'm not going to go over all of these
details that story is
is a little bit terrifying but i'm just
going to point to one particular trace
at the end of this
which is our concern here which will
point us to
the limitations of branching on
variables which is intrinsic to these
kind of algorithms
first technique is i want to avoid
redundant traces so if you look at
the the trace that i just showed you you
can see two portions are exactly the
same i i want to
avoid that and that's easy technique
from
uh obd literature known as unique node
you have a hash table you make sure that
you do not construct a node if you have
something similar to it and you can
easily check that
if you do it in a certain fashion in
this case you start by
making sure that leaf nodes are unique
and then when you do that
nodes like this become easily detectable
that they are duplicates so you don't do
this you do that instead
and then you get this now this doesn't
help with time but it helps with space
it's essential
unique node and i don't know if you
realize but this is already in obd now
compilation now the second technique
uh that people did is which help with
time
is known as formula caching so
the idea is if you look at the search
space and here's two paths
and research three different variable
instantiations
of this formula but the residual formula
is equivalent so i try
to avoid compiling this again given that
i already did this and you do this by
caching the formulas and the results on
them
and then looking them up and the third
technique is component analysis and
uh what happens here is
once as you fix the values of your
variables your input formulas start
disconnecting
and you get independent components and
the idea is you want to spawn
independent ppl searches on these
independent components
and you add all of these guys you end up
finding that your trace
is a decision then enough now i skipped
intermediate traces you add this
technique the trace becomes this you
have this technique i'll go skipping
this we're just going to focus on this
for the interest of time
and let me just show you this visually
so here's an input formula
i i start doing uh case analysis um
okay i i froze for a second here
i have this input formula i i doing case
analysis on variable a
i set a i simplify the formula it
disconnects into two independent clauses
i spawn independent searches on them
this ends up being this this ends up
being that and i couldn't join
all right so i can join these guys this
is the other case similarly
if you unfold mutation you you basically
get this guy
and now here's the punchline the
punchline is
this is a decision dnf it is not a
deterministic dnf
it is not a dnf it's a very specific
type of trace
the main use of these algorithms whether
explicitly for model counting or whether
to compile
into circuits that allow model counting
the embassy uses model counting and
their traces is this
what's the significance the significance
is remember the exponential separation
you don't need this to count you can
count using this guy
and these guys are exponentially
separated
but because you're splitting on
variables and and i hope you see
intuitively why splitting in variables
got you into this guy
you are basically missing an exponential
gap there because of this
all right this would be one of the
things now the question is
uh you you can see more about the story
of traces and all of that
later uh let's look at a visual visually
so see what's going on here what's going
on is
to do counting i need determinism like
this
if i have another node i need the alpha
and vector to be usually exclusive they
are here
and that's sufficient to do counting but
what i'm getting is this
i'm getting determinism in a specific
way where i have x and something not
x and that so i'm getting these decision
dnfs instead of these guys
and that is basically a sub optimality
mix of optimality and
if you're bound to do this we
established this idea a while back and
we showed that basically all of these
model counters and knowledge compilers
they all have these traces and they're
limited in this particular way
it's hard to break from this with this
algorithm because it starts by saying
try x try not x committed
decision now i'm gonna tell you about
another problem that i'm interested in
which is
even more for me at least at this point
bothers me more than this one
we're going to talk about how to break
from this
using these algorithms how do i get
something that is determine
decomposable and not deterministic i may
not be interested in determinism i don't
want to count i just want to do
existential quantification i'm
interested
in something like let's say functional
synthesis or other things i don't i just
want extensive multiplication how do you
do that
the minute you start and say try x
trimet x
determinism you're solving another
problem
what do i do how do i utilize these
techniques
so that i do not commit myself to
terminalism first second if i commit
myself to determinism not to decision
determinism but the more general
he's a dilemma by the way even though
there's a whole bunch of
uh knowledge compilers and model
counters out there which effectively
compile
uh the deterministic dnfs
there is no dnnf compiler in existence
as far as being
maybe somebody has somewhere built
something that is being used commonly
and the reason is what i just told
everything we have we built based on
these techniques that commit to
branching on variables
get you in the world of determinism get
you in trouble okay so
and the dilemma if you want to try to do
something there was some ideas about
doing something
the infrastructure that we've built and
automated based on branching on
variables
is so sophisticated and so vast it's
really hard to do something like this
so the short story and i i hope i have
about uh
five minutes or so i'm gonna have to run
quickly through
what's gonna come up next the short
story and main inside
which is i'm just going to give you
evidence theoretically and practically
that's very promising it's not a
concluding story or not
conclusive uh but hopefully to motivate
people to work on this and to think
about this like i'm doing now
is we're gonna do something interesting
we're gonna try to
avoid the commitment
that splitting on variables gets us into
while still using the infrastructure
that we've built
based on branching on various how are
you to do this
remember the very first slides technique
from
that we've seen in extended resolution
where i'm going to use auxiliary
variables to emulate
the process of branching on formulas so
as we've seen in extended resolution you
can do this by adding an auxiliary
variable and equating it to alpha so now
if i set
x not x i'm branching on alpha
but you can do this more interesting or
more generally i don't have to have
mutually exclusive cases
you can do something like this also
using utility variables so if i have
something like that
i can go and and write these two by
introducing this variable now if you set
x to false then you're making the case
alpha you said x to true you're making
better so now i'm branching on alpha or
beta
which do not have to be mutually
exclusive again using the
question is how do you operationalize
this does this work
now auxiliary variables are used
commonly
in sat solving but now it's not as they
say
because that's a very specific context
here is a little bit more general
context you can't just add auxiliary
variables as you'll see
so the last set of results i just have a
few more slides come from this paper we
put on the archive a couple of years ago
did this as a phd student and it was on
his way out so
uh i'm back to thinking about this now
um
and it's part of the reason i'm i'm
talking about the subject
the idea to try to formalize this notion
of adding variables so the idea is
here's what
you have to require something uh if you
have the original
function this guy over x variables i'm
going to add these auxiliary variables y
and i'm going to require only one
condition that if you essentially
quantify the variables y from this guy
you get back that time
okay now this sounds familiar for sad
people because this is good enough for
sad
well it's not good enough for our
purpose as it turns out to be
and and the reason if you you know and
there's a whole bunch of
techniques that people have proposed for
adding absolutely variables um
particularly in set context and these
are some of them they all satisfy this
property
the the problem is because there is no
quality algorithm for existentially
quantifying variables out of
deterministic dnf this is not good
enough so that means
if you add these auxiliary variables to
satisfy this property and then this
becomes very
you know easier this will blow up if you
use variable splitting but if you
do this it works that's not good enough
because i cannot existentially quantify
the variables to get that
so let's say you're doing sharp set you
cannot do sharp set on this car
you have to existentially quantify and i
can't do it so that's not good
now if you want to do the jump from
decision dnf to deterministic
you need an additional condition and
that can help you i'm not going to do
this now
but i'm going to do the next jump from
determinism to without determinism
and and this is enough for that all
right because as you remember
i can existentially quantify variables
and i
while affording to lose determinism so
let me wrap up here with this
picture here's the picture uh the
picture is
you give me a boolean formula and i'm
trying to compile it using the dpl style
which commits to determinism
and therefore it will be giving me the
deterministic the compose of a negation
of a form
it's going to blow up it doesn't work
let's say because of succinctness that
this bonding formula doesn't have
a representation in that circuit type so
i'm going to go and
do this e and f transformation and get
you this
function or formula with auxiliary
variables
and now i'm gonna compile it and
effectively what i'm doing now is i'm
long branching on on formulas and
let's say i succeed in this case and
i'll show you theoretical
and practical results that shows that's
possible it's not just a theoretical
exercise and then what i do is
i know if i existentially quantify i
can't get what i want right because
that's not easy but i can always get
easily at the nnf
so the idea is take your formula add
auxiliary variables
because you added them now i can compile
into deterministic decomposable
existentially quantity variables get
dna and now what i did is i showed you
how you can build a
dnf compiler using
deterministic dna compilers what is the
thing the trick is to operate in a
bigger space
so fine i'll allow you to split on
variables but those would be in
a larger space and therefore you
effectively branch upon formulas
and and just like to end by a couple of
pieces of evidence that make this very
encouraging
as i thought that the picture is not
complete so this is preliminary
but pretty exciting the first result is
believe it or not let's look at this
picture we know of
boolean formulas families where adding a
single auxiliary variable single
those those formulas will blow up they
have no deterministic decomposable
representation
okay for polysize you add a single
auxiliary variable
then they do so this will fail by adding
zulu variable i know i
should be able to get this and therefore
i get that
and you'll see this in this paper a
single variable can allow you to
have an exponential uh separation there
all right and and use this technique we
experimented a little bit with
the bounded variable edition in this
paper and this is the technique
introduced there
and both theoretical and practical
results
one of the results that i didn't mention
is that
cnf that have bounded primal tree with
can be efficiently compiled into this
form
uh the the the compilation algorithm
time and space complex is only
exponential and between
so we showed that if you apply vva
in a limited way then
you bound the increase agreement in fact
we even found
a class of formulas family of formulas
where
by adding auxiliary variables i can go
from unbounded through it to boundary
treatment
so i guarantee you that there's no
guarantee that you can compile these
uh for deterministic dnf but by adding
the resilient verbs i guarantee you
they will be compiled efficiently which
is pretty interesting
and we had some preliminary experiment
results
showing this again very primitive very
limited but
it's evidence of promise and this was
based on the
bva where we either ran ctd is a is a
compiler i built
a while back based on the techniques
that were mentioned
it was actually probably the first
compiler
for decision dnf uh circuits
and this is running it on the plain
input versus on
an input with auxiliary variables and
then forgetting and you can see the
interesting thing here is it's not like
i'm getting twice as fast or something
it's i can do all i cannot do which is
which is pretty uh interesting and
just so that uh people who know c2d
compilers you think
i wrote this a while back and it became
obsolete it's even only in 32 bits
cannot even run on modern machines so i
was on sabbatical last war and guess
what
i've been rewriting ctd and preparing a
new version 364 bit should be coming out
soon
and within a flood we may include
support for dnf compilation
based on the ideas that i just mentioned
now
so i'm done folks in conclusion
this business of splitting or branching
out variables versus formulas it's been
around right but i i think
it requires this more systematic
treatment it's so essential it has to be
a first-class
citizen in our thinking and our analysis
and the the notion of circuits and
traces
uh gives us a very sharp lens to look at
what's going on and the bottom line is
you have two genres going from uh
variables to sentences
and then within sentences there are
finer distinctions i didn't
say enough to make this very clear the
second claim
but i hope you got at the end so it's
not like one size fits all there is
all kind of ways in which you can branch
on sentences
and um we just need
to do more on this and i think this is a
critical thing to do
these serious jumps in the efficiency of
building knowledge compilers and
underneath the research algorithms and
i think this notion of of using usually
valuables is very very promising
because it capitalizes on the vast
infrastructure that we've built over the
years as far as
um sat technology and what sat
technology gave us so
i wish to thank you and uh again you can
find more about all of this
from the youtube channel of my group
thank you
thank you for the very nice talk and
we'll open the floor to
question um let me clap on behalf of
everybody
since we can't do that properly but we
have about 10 10 minutes for questions
so uh
encourage people to either speak up and
ask a question or to drop questions
into the chat windows
and let's see we already have one here
in the chat window from uh
from stephen i guess it's stephen gawked
are there results on how clause learning
relates to knowledge compilation
similar to how dpl relates to obdds
oh yes in fact the
knowledge compilers the modern ones
and the examples are uh c2d and
uh d4 d4 is from pierre marquis probably
the latest as far as being very modern
has the related advantage
they do use closed learning so i i kept
it
dpll and you know dpll is not exactly
modern set software's right
however uh what i talked about actually
applies for modern set software
now there is a paper with umut ostok
that says uh which is the latest
paper on doing this knowledge
compilation while exploiting closed
learning and
you know all of the latest technology of
backtracking to the assertion level
that's all integrated with these things
um
it is in jail 2018 um
and it comes with proof of correctness
cashier which is a model counter
from a while back did this initially and
had some very interesting observations
about subtleties when you integrate
close learning
in these compilation algorithms and
we have a more recent one uh with a
detailed proof of correctness so check
that paper
it's an intricate story frankly the
interaction with closed learning and all
of that but
yes okay good okay
uh let's see i have a question also
maybe other people can formulate their
own questions in the meantime but i was
wondering from the very beginning of
your talk i was struck
that uh branching on for formulas is
sort of like doing cuts and proofs
so you think of a if you have a sequence
calculus proof and you cut on a formula
that means you
split into two sub proofs one where
you've assumed the formula's true
and the other way to see the formula is
false and so i'm wondering
you talked as i understand it just about
expressibility with different classes of
circuits what about
or different classes of formulas have
has anyone looked into
proof complexity based on restricting
cuts to formulas in these classes
i don't know this is not my area in fact
i'm pleased to hear this and
in fact if later you can send me
a link i would like to see those because
i'm looking for insights
and so i don't know the short story
but i i i want to hear more
about it because that
see one of the issues is how do you
do this right so i gave you
promising evidence but we don't yet have
a systematic way of doing it that really
works broadly and
it's all about the choices of what i
mean sure you can mechanize it using
additional variables but what do you do
what do you equate x to uh
we don't have a theory we have a you
know we have some ideas
and the more the better so there may be
some insights from what you're talking
about that can guide us
a little bit into how do we make these
choices practically
right yeah so to make those questions
precise suppose you allow
in the sql calculus cuts on the on i
guess d and nf formulas i guess that was
your weakest class
and does that allow formulas to be does
that allow proofs become
super polynomially shorter for instance
when dealing
working in prop and propositional logic
would be a good question
as far as i know no one's looked at this
kind of thing at all so
um okay but there are this inside batman
inside down arithmetic
okay may i add an insight into this guys
um i think from a pragmatic point of
view you can look at the structure of
these things that you're trying to
compile they have a lot of structure the
formulas
are part of that specification
and so you can you don't have to
actually
uh define you know what formulas to
split on and so on and so forth
just take the structure that somebody
has written into their spec
and see if you can actually take
advantage of that
my experience is that that always you
know that insight that went into putting
that spec
is going to help in figuring out how to
actually analyze it
right i agree and in fact
this set of simple results on bfa and
pre-width is along these lines karen
so i can add variables to reduce tree
width for example
right and for to do that i need the
structure of the input formula
and i'm now thinking at another level
like your suggestion right yes
okay um there's a comment in the chat
window for the people who want to follow
up on the talk there's
a link to the paper of uh sock and
and on on there okay uh
any other questions or comments either
from panelists or attendees
they gave me a hard time a month ago now
they're being kind sorry
oh maybe you answered any questions back
then
all right yes yes thank you
yeah thank you for very nice talk oh
wait we have a question
back up so super critique asks um
is it possible to decide whether a given
formula has a succinct
d dnf
deterministic is it possible to decide
uh well we do have a tree with guarantee
uh but of course that's not complete so
if if
the primal key would and not just primal
through it you know how it is with
with these uh graph theoretic parameters
there's different ways to abstract the
formulas the primal graph
incidence graph this and that and
there's different kind of parameters
so there's a whole set of these fixed
parameter guarantees that actually
guarantee you efficient compilation
the simplest one is three width of the
primal graph but
which is nice uh but of course in
general
and of course we know whole thing a
number of things where this will blow up
but i don't know full characterization
is
probably really difficult to have
okay all right
um all right thank you very much again
we'll take a
three minute break thank you everyone
uh we'll take a three-minute break and
uh start promptly
at the half hour for most of us very
good whatever whatever time zone you're
in it's probably on your head
and i'm sorry i have to leave the
session because i have to go teach next
so
right all right very good all right
thank you guys
okay thank you
okay